We have a problem.
Somebody
pull your head off,
might make it here for a while.
Was it good for you
to be the greatest adventure?
I mean,
the stuff has been really
excellent.
Cookie.
You're in the middle of a war one that's been going on forever.
They talking about,
you asked talking would be worse.
Killings,
witness the biggest covered up in Houston.
Kicking,
get involved in these people's problems together.
Hell Oh my agents.
So that they have a fighting chance against the sub machine guns or some of the
most dangerous characters and the history of American criminality.
It's a bigger idea than just the concert.
We all have the same struggles.
Painting
for sure.
I don't,
I just believe
it's not,
you're late.
[inaudible]
quite a real.
Uh,
thank you Brian.
Really appreciate you being here.
Uh,
let's start from the early days,
if that's okay with you.
Sure.
So sure.
You grew up.
Is it,
it's good.
Uh,
you,
uh,
you grew up just to on the other side of the hill in the valley.
Uh,
and,
uh,
you,
it all kind of started,
uh,
the way you put it with your grandmother,
a little Jewish woman named Sonia who believed in you despite,
you know,
you not doing well in school and you kind of struggling as a kid.
Uh,
can you talk about what she meant to you?
Um,
what she meant?
Well,
she was the single person that would support me or validate,
uh,
you know,
giving me human personal validation.
Um,
but I think she spotted such desperation in me,
um,
that it was attractive to her in a way because there was,
she would always tell me,
I'm going to be special.
You're going all the way.
Um,
and I'm thinking I'll go all the way where,
where am I going?
All the way to.
But,
um,
because she would look at these report cards,
cards and I have,
there were always like all D's and F's.
And so there was really no evidence to support what she was saying,
you know,
like,
um,
so,
but it was very important to have some one person that consistently believed in
me and then isolated this one trait that she thought I could do and was doing.
Um,
even though it wasn't as,
as refined as it is now,
but have,
which was to use the power of curiosity to learn interactively with people.
Um,
and then of course I've taken it to some other level where I've have curiosity
conversations every two weeks.
I have for at least 30 years,
actually for 30 years,
every two weeks,
uh,
faithfully.
Um,
and in these curiosity conversations,
it's just,
you know,
it's science,
medicine,
politics,
religion,
technology have been a lot of people in your business,
some of the progenitors of things that are very important,
some of the founders of companies,
particularly yours,
in fact.
Um,
and so it's been really edifying and I've found ways through these curiosity
conversations to,
um,
to learn different perspectives.
And that's the,
that's something you just don't do with Ai.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
you're kind of how you got started in film seems very kind of serendipitous.
You were hearing these guys literally having a conversation out out your window
about kind of an easy,
a job opening at,
uh,
at Warner brothers.
Um,
when you were a kid,
you weren't dead set on film.
Did you want to do something else?
Um,
well I,
I was,
I assigned myself to do something else,
but I don't know if I wanted to,
I was going to law school,
I was going to go,
I went to USC and then it was going to go to USC law school,
which had upset except it too.
Um,
but I didn't really,
I didn't really that I passed the bar,
So I,
um,
I didn't think I'd pass the bar really if I broke it down,
even make it through the first year.
But I thought,
well,
this is a direction.
It's a choice.
Um,
so I'll take this choice.
But it was like within the first week of the summer,
I overheard in my apartment complex,
actually very close to here on ocean avenue.
What was it?
Ocean avenue was right across the street from this little elementary school,
but ocean and,
and,
and like fifth or something.
And
I overheard these two guys going,
oh my God,
this was the easiest job.
It was so cushy,
cushy,
like really grabbed me.
I never heard the word cushy.
The Guy said,
yeah,
we had,
I had a company card.
I very,
I really at 40 hours a week I'd get paid,
but there really wasn't much to do.
And then I'm listening in even closer and I like pull the drapes closed in my
little apartment and opened the window further so I could make sure that I
really was listening,
could hear what they're saying.
They said,
Oh yeah,
I was at Warner brothers from someone named Peter Connect.
Peter Connect was,
I didn't know he was the head of Warner brothers legal department.
So a conversation ends and I just immediately dial,
you know,
I get four,
four,
one one I get ahold of,
I get the number of Warner brothers pictures,
ask for Peter Connect.
And I said,
I understand that you could be,
um,
you might need a law clerk this summer.
And can I please come in and,
and interview for the job?
Of course he did because I just heard it.
And so now all of a sudden I'm meeting with Peter Connect at three o'clock and
getting the job to work at Warner brothers like at three 15.
So now I had a job and it happened to be,
you know,
it was in alignment with the path of going to law school and um,
and really what the job was kind of a bullshit job,
but those guys were right.
It was kind of a bullshit job where you just sat in a little teeny office about
like this big,
like this and it was with no windows,
a little desk and you'd wait,
do either file papers or deliver papers to somebody for Warner brothers.
So a couple of weeks go in,
I've,
I do have a company car,
all that stuff.
All those things were true and about how cushy it was.
And I have to deliver papers to,
uh,
ironically Warren Beatty.
Warren Beatty was huge.
You know,
this is a while ago.
He was a gigantic movie star,
like is big and movie stars you could get.
But he,
you know,
he's also a star and he was a writer and he was a director and I think you'd
already done shampoo if I'm not wrong.
And um,
when I ain't even have to deliver these papers,
he lives at the Beverly Wilshire Hotel.
So I go to the Beverly Wilshire Hotel and I'm waiting at the desk and it's one
of his assistants comes down,
says,
hey,
me like Hemi the papers kid.
And so I say,
I just think to say,
well I can't hand you the papers,
I have to hand them directly to mister Beatty.
And the guy goes like a version of like,
you're full of shit.
But um,
he says,
just hand me the papers.
I said,
these papers are invalid unless I hand them directly to mister Beatty.
And I said it with enough conviction and repeatedly that they said,
okay,
okay.
And so then I,
and I'm intercepted by another assistant,
like the higher level assistant,
I say the same thing and persuade him,
he said,
okay,
just hand them to papers.
And then you leave.
I go up there and I'm in and I hand him the papers,
I generate a connection and I turned that little moment into an hour
conversation with Warren Beatty,
which was really,
really informational.
It was amazing.
And I,
I,
I just got a lot of,
I got a lot out of it.
And also I got confidence from doing it for having him say yes.
How did you have that kind of healthy sense of entitlement or Chutzpah,
uh,
to,
you know,
your 23 year old legal clerk to,
to be in the presence of Warren Beatty and,
and,
uh,
you know,
have his ear for an hour.
Um,
well
I,
um,
I don't,
I get that.
Well,
I got it from my group.
My grandmother helped.
That'll Chutzpah.
Um,
I think,
I think I've always been into disrupting my comfort zone and I do it
professionally now and it's,
it's really an additive.
Um,
I know that you guys had Simon Sinek,
he did a Google talk for you guys.
He does.
And he's has won two of the top five,
um,
Google,
I'm sorry,
ted talks in the world and one of them's on the why,
why you do what you do not.
So he diagnosed me cause I got to be friends with him and he said my why was and
cause he'll ask me what was the most important moment in your childhood,
school,
school life experience.
And I explain it then he connects all these dots and the very end he goes,
I think you think your why.
And I've known him now a couple of years.
He says,
I,
he,
I think you think your why is curiosity,
but that's your how your why is you hate bullies,
which I just learned like two weeks ago.
I mean we're,
it's really came together for me cause I really do hate bullies.
Um,
and so I think that was part of it.
Like I,
I think I was just always,
whether it's a bully or just the man in general,
um,
I,
I wouldn't say I'm defiant against it.
I've just,
uh,
I'm cool with it.
I'm cool with going up against being,
I'm very happy being the underdog.
In fact,
I'm not happy being,
you know,
beyond that actually.
And that's why I probably have made,
I've,
I've produced I think a hundred movies and,
uh,
seven or eight really important tell,
you know,
television shows and they're all startups.
And I think I like startups.
I like,
um,
having an idea of building it out of zero and then case building it to the point
that some,
that it has value.
And once I've do that to the point that it's,
you know,
that gas becomes a solid,
then I like to start on another one and a long answer.
That's a great answer.
Uh,
Warren Beatty was just the tip of the iceberg.
You spoke to,
you know,
Lou Wasserman,
Mel Brooks.
Am I right about that?
Uh,
and,
and it seems like you kind of understood,
you had this fundamental understanding that your career was going to be made on
relationships and not on kind of arise a direct rise through kind of the
meritocracy.
Uh,
how did you have that understanding?
So,
so young?
Um,
well,
okay.
Okay.
That's cool.
Um,
well just one differentiation.
I think that,
um,
that I,
I didn't think I didn't,
I mean,
look,
relationships are extremely important,
but I think insight is more important and what I would gained out of these
conversations that I'd have with Warren Beatty or,
you know,
what I did is I quit going to law school.
Hope to see if we can capture this.
But I quit going to law school because I saw that this was a method that would
be pretty awesome for me.
And I say to my boss,
Peter Connect,
I'm going just going to stay here.
But I did happen to notice way down the hall,
there was a vacant office.
This office was twice as big as his,
but he didn't care cause he'd started with Jack Warner and you know,
like a zillion years ago.
And so he just goes,
oh,
I'll get it for you.
He gets me this giant office,
the size,
the size of this room.
But you know,
like really it would to union secretaries there.
So now I have this amazing big office and I can use this for like the Brian
Grazer business even though I'm working there and still making my $5 an hour.
So once I got this big office and I extended for an additional year than every
single day,
whether I was delivering papers or not,
I was using a similar speech.
I'd say,
hi,
my name is Brian Grazer.
I work at Warner Brothers business affairs.
I kind of fudge that a little bit.
Um,
and I know everything about your boss.
I would love to have a conversation with him the last only five minutes and I
absolutely do not want a job.
So I do that every single day so that every single day I could meet someone that
was really making a difference in the entertainment business,
could be television or movies and,
and so it wasn't that I counted on the relationship,
it was more about a demystification of how this whole system worked.
You like,
ultimately what I was able to learn,
even very young,
was like how leveraged got created and used in a,
as a tool in our,
in,
you know,
in the entertainment business.
And so I,
um,
Kinda stayed doing that for about a year and a half.
And just before I got the boot,
uh,
because I kept using the Warner brothers assets for me.
Um,
I got this one big meeting with like who I really wanted to meet with Lou
Wasserman.
Lew Wasserman was like the dawn of the entertainment business,
the modern,
and Tim is,
it was the most powerful mythic man in the entertainment business.
He,
he,
uh,
was really the founder of MCA universal.
And,
and literally he was the guy that,
uh,
that everything,
everything in the entertainment business revolved around Lew Wasserman.
So I find a way to meet Lew Wasserman and I'm already to sort of try to,
um,
have a conversation with him and he sort of puts his hands up in the air and he
says,
just wait a second.
You're not coming into my office.
And I thought,
well,
like everybody has going into his office,
but no go.
So he comes back with a legal tab and a pencil and he said,
take these.
So I take him and he says,
put the pencil to the paper and it has greater value than it did,
as separate parts.
Now get outta here.
And,
which was kind of embarrassing,
but what I realized was he was saying that you,
you don't really have anything,
uh,
you might have like a gift to get into people's office and turn and create a
conversation,
but you don't own anything.
So I realized I better put the pencil to the paper and start writing ideas and I
kind of industrialized,
uh,
sort of the idea of business and I every day have many ideas and send them
registered mail to myself.
And I ended up with a box of hundreds of ideas,
including the,
the one called splash that was a man falling in love with a mermaid starring Tom
Hanks and in many others.
Um,
but I realized that the,
you don't,
unless you can't codify or you know,
codify,
right,
original ideas and prove that they're valuable,
you have to make them valuable.
Um,
you don't have anything.
I want to talk about idea generation for a second.
I imagine curiosity conversations probably play into different ideas and you've
talked about how they've even turned into movies.
Um,
do you have any other kind of processes to kind of help spur creativity and come
up with ideas?
Um,
do I have other ways to spur creativity?
Uh,
well,
I read,
um,
but I don't really read,
I don't really read fiction.
I mean,
I've just,
uh,
the first 15 years of my being a producer,
I just did comedies.
Comedies are fiction,
uh,
for the most,
well,
I don't know,
whatever you think they're,
they're kind of a combination.
Um,
I like to curiosity conversations because I just,
you learn,
um,
I know that,
I know that knowing your inner truth,
whatever that is,
and really diagnosing what that is so you're not bullshitting yourself.
I know the inner truth of that.
Once you start to create,
understand that and it's schematic of that is a way to build ideas.
I mean,
the movie for the Friday Night Lights was,
was about me.
It was really just because I got cut in a very humiliating way from high school
football from coach Ogawa.
He cut me in front of like 250 kids.
And the pain of that was so awesome.
So I mean,
it was so memorable to me that I was able to sort of think it through and go
like,
well,
when,
when he pointed to Richard Cox over there and he said he was quarterback and he
said to Perry,
Shell,
my,
your nose guard.
And he said to Brian Grazer,
uh,
your status.
And I said,
tailback.
He said,
incorrect cut.
I was no longer a human being that in that moment.
And I thought I was able to,
I was able to start catalog that and many other experiences,
but that one in particular,
I realized that that lived inside this book called Friday Night Lights because
anything you read has multiple interpretations.
Right.
So
I want to skip ahead chronologically a little bit.
You're,
uh,
you're in in the 80s,
you're working at Paramont.
Um,
and do you want to meet Ron Howard?
he had done the Andy Griffith show.
You'd done happy days.
What about Ron Howard?
You know,
it almost seems like you knew you wanted to partner with them before you,
you met him.
Um,
what about him,
you know,
made you say,
this is the guy,
this is the guy I want to work with for the rest of my life.
Um,
well I,
I didn't,
I actually didn't know,
I just had this quote of meeting a new person every day.
So I saw Ron Howard out of my office and I yelled out at it.
I'm like,
Hey,
you know,
like the hat,
Bruh,
Bruh.
And he didn't know I was and I scared him,
Kinda mean.
And um,
and then I called his office and I got to meet with you.
I've found a way,
you know,
cause you can get an,
if you really work at it,
you know,
if you're resourceful,
you can,
you can and polite.
You can get people to meet with you.
And,
um,
but then when he walked into my office,
he had this sort of aura of goodness or it's perceptible to me that he had this
energetically,
he had an,
he had had goodness about him.
I'm sure you guys feel stuff like that.
Right?
You know,
you feel like,
oh,
that person's like bad vibe.
Don't think I want to be around that or so,
um,
it's a very important metric to me how I feel energetically towards somebody
because I can,
I can think about it.
You feel it,
that truth.
And then I often just think,
how will this end?
And if you extrapolate,
build that out and you feel like,
I think this will end bad,
then you,
you shouldn't start.
But with Ron,
I fell like he is.
Um,
I just think he just had this aura of goodness about him.
It was like a,
it was kind of a biblical for me.
Of course.
I was looking for that probably.
I didn't know he could actually direct.
I mean,
I had no idea he could direct.
I just liked him and thought I should support a guy that seemed good.
It seemed like it worked out.
It did work.
Done.
Um,
uh,
can you give us kind of a story of the making of a movie that seemed very
unlikely that it would be made kind of at the start and you know,
you kind of willed it into,
into fruition?
Um,
I've had a lot of them.
I mean the first one was splash because it's hundreds of rejections over the
course of like five years.
Just every person rejected it repeatedly,
you know,
every studio or every buyer.
Um,
which caused me to well get tough,
you know,
like become
durable that way.
Um,
and I think,
I think I had,
what I learned was
splash,
even though it was a man falling over the mermaid.
It's inner theme,
it's interior theme was about love.
And I realized in retrospect that people through the script or through my pitch
couldn't see that,
um,
or they just didn't like it.
I don't know.
But I think it's,
I think if you can pitch a theme,
if you know,
if you have a story,
but you know the interior theme and you try to sell and you case build a sell
your theme themes are often,
uh,
irrefutable.
Um,
so,
uh,
but I just didn't know that then.
So I had hundreds,
a hundred rejections.
I finally got it made.
It was brutal.
Um,
and then the movie that models this better best for me is cause I,
I was this movie called American gangster.
I don't know if you ever saw that of Russell Crowe and Denzel Washington,
but it,
um,
it,
it was many,
many,
many years later after splash and the studio decided they were going to fire the
director just months before we're start starting to shoot.
And we already had Russell Crowe in the movie.
Everyone,
sorry,
a Denzel Washington in the movie didn't have Russell Crowe.
Um,
we had a director,
we'd already spent $2 million,
but they just felt like this director scares them.
They've thought about it a lot,
scares them.
It's,
it's going to be a bigger loss if they actually make the movie.
They're rather just write down $32 million and that's really a lot of money.
Um,
even today it's a lot of money,
but then it was crazy.
That was like 12 years ago.
Um,
and that's how scared they were of,
of this guy.
And anyways,
I was able to immediately recontextualize it and get better actors in a much
better director.
So I sort of forced them after they took the right down to talk to me again
about American gangster,
which they didn't want to do.
They said we'll take the write down,
but don't ever say American or gangster to us ever again.
I love the story of how you got a eight mile made.
Can you talk about that a little bit?
How you met M and m and um,
uh,
slowly kind of convinced him to do it?
Um,
well,
yeah.
Well I,
I was out sir.
Okay.
Very quickly.
So,
um,
you said,
how do I get ideas?
I mean I get ideas just by,
you know,
it sounds so simple,
but just by trying to be as present as possible.
So I happened to be in a taxi cab in New York and it was like guys,
we've been around and everything,
but I'm listening to this faint conversation going on in the taxi cabs,
you know on the radio,
local,
local radio,
local Manhattan radio and ODB old dirty bastard is being interviewed by some
talk show guy and he makes like in a minute stand and be barely makes any sense
and it's just hard to really understand it.
But I thought what kind of a guy wants to be called old dirty bastard?
I mean that was his choice to be called that.
I thought that's an interesting choice.
So I think I met her,
go meet this ODB.
So this is like 25 or 23 years ago.
So I go meet ODB and like he was a trip,
you know,
like he wouldn't let me into a studio and everything was a cost Allah cart
thing.
If you want to go in the studio,
it's going to cost this.
If you want to do that.
So I just think,
wow,
this guy is so interesting.
He's funny.
And also kind of scary at the same time.
So after I met ODB DB,
then I thought I'd meet this character slick Rick,
the wears a patch on his eye,
rappers really kind of comical British dude.
And then I go through this series of Chuck d,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And I'm thinking,
wow,
this is like a movement.
You know this east,
you know east coast hip hop is like a movement.
It can be funny.
It could be the voice of the inner city.
It's a lot of things.
Were you,
did you listen to a lot of like nineties hip hop at the time?
I'm not really,
no.
I mean I know.
No,
that isn't what got me into it.
I didn't listen to nineties hip hop before I met ODB.
Okay.
Just a funny name.
And a guy wanted to go,
you call me ODB,
you know,
like being insistent upon it.
That was made me want to go see him.
I didn't know about the Wu Tang clan and,
and so then I know,
so I didn't know anything about it.
And then I happened to be,
because I was still doing curiosity conversations.
I've started them,
I met with Frank Rich,
who was the editor of the New York Times.
Very,
very she,
she guy.
And I start telling him about,
he was tough.
We're talking about something very high flute,
you know,
probably,
Broadway musicals and stuff,
which is quite expert at.
And I say something about hip hop and he goes,
oh,
he treated it as an inferior subculture.
Like it was less than.
And I thought,
I don't think as less than,
I think this is the culture,
not a subculture,
much less an inferior subculture.
And I kinda thought I'd build a story to prove him wrong.
And that's where it sort of came about.
Then I found a way,
I didn't know who should be in it.
I've spent years trying to figure it out and I tried to get spike Lee to do it
and he was cool but no go.
And then I was just watching the vmax and I see the camera,
this is like seven or eight years after the Frank Rich conversation or seven
years,
and the camera crumbed across the audience and it just heats on m and M on his
face.
And I didn't know who he was,
but he had this sort of icy steel glare.
And then all of a sudden he started laughing or being really fluid.
And I thought,
wow,
what a lot of range that dude has.
Like he could be that then that.
So then I wanted to meet him.
So then I met M and m and a
dre came with them and it was just,
it was very,
um,
controlled.
Like I tried to talk to him,
but he wouldn't look at me.
So,
uh,
if I'm looking at him like this,
he was there,
oh,
sorry.
He would just wouldn't look at me.
We were looking,
we were at each other,
but he would look the other way out my window.
And,
and then he,
he goes after about 30 minutes and I keep trying to get him to talk.
He goes,
I'm out.
I'm thinking can be out.
You didn't say one thing.
Um,
and they go and now he's out.
I go,
wait a minute.
I said,
uh,
come on.
I mean,
you could animate,
you can say something,
you know?
And like he,
I think I made a mad or some,
and he came back kind of pissed at me,
but then talked and then he told this whole story that kind of later became kind
of deaf.
It became what eight mile was.
So that was it.
That was the m and m of it all.
I love that story and I love him.
He's a really super professional.
I mean,
he's amazing gifted person.
You said something really interesting earlier,
which is you kind of started to understand like leverage and the laws of
leverage.
Then you used kind of Warner brothers like initially as a platform to meet all
these interesting people.
Can you kind of unpack that?
Because as a producer you probably use leverage a lot.
You're almost like an entrepreneur for movies.
Um,
yeah.
Can you unpack just the,
the idea of leverage and using that?
Well,
okay,
sure.
Uh,
I think I can,
um,
well
you have to have an idea now the idea that you have,
this is so much like a startup.
The idea that you have or one that I would,
one would have,
doesn't have to be what you end up doing.
It can just continue to change form change,
form,
change,
change form.
Um,
the two things that are relevant.
One is to know the spa,
to have the spark of an idea.
So we have something to say to somebody if you have nothing to say to somebody
other than like,
Hey,
what are you doing?
I always feel like you have to start with something that's like the gift of the
conversation.
If you have nothing to say,
even as smile,
even if you're super smart,
but nothing to say
it doesn't go anywhere.
It's not going to,
you can't build nothing into something.
You have to build the germ of something and the something,
and you've said that when you reach out to people that you can't be a generic
insight into them as well.
It has to be something kind of unique to you that you've recognized.
Yeah,
I mean my,
in these conversations that I have,
it can't be googleable if it's googleable then like just Google it,
you know,
like you have to say,
you have to ask a question or have an insight or a gift,
a rim.
When I met Dre one of the first times I said,
uh,
I asked him feed,
heard the musical composition to Ernst golds,
uh,
composition of exodus,
I think it was like 1979 it was really,
really beautiful.
And I brought it up not to be a wiseguy but I brought it up because when his
music's really clicks is on fire,
it's,
it's very melodic.
It's beautiful.
So he's got rap,
you know,
he's,
you know what it is.
So he has a unique component of that.
Some of his,
some of his songs when they really work,
they have beauty to them and are melodic and I thought he would really gain by
hearing this.
He would dig it just like listening to Hans Zimmer or James Horn or something.
But this was even,
this was a signature piece that really stuck with me and he appreciated it,
you know,
like,
cause I had something to say.
Um,
so or just recently I was at your,
uh,
I'll say,
cause I was at your Google Cecily camp,
but I get invited to go to that and I love it.
It's so amazing.
It's a privilege.
And last year you guys had Kevin Durant showed and was one of the speakers and I
just,
I don't know.
I know basketball mostly just through my kids,
you know,
cause they,
these two boys,
like they love basketball.
So they knew Kevin Duran is,
but I sort of barely know Kevin Duran is and he,
um,
goes on this friend's boat.
Okay.
So we're now going to go,
says Lee,
we've done the conference,
you know,
for the day.
Now we go to the boat,
there's a boat.
A friend of mine got a boat,
he's on the boat,
Kevin Durant's shows up and when he leaves he says,
Hey,
uh,
you know,
I'd love to connect with you when I get,
when we get back and I'm going to,
I'll be coming to la.
I'm thinking,
okay,
here's my number,
but I,
I didn't think you'd really follow up because you know,
what are the chances,
you know,
the chances are so,
but he does follow up.
It's like weeks,
weeks later he,
you know,
he says wanting to get together and have lunch.
He's,
I'm at the Beverly Hills Hotel,
we're playing a clippers.
Sure.
So we have lunch.
And I just say,
I'm inventing stuff to talk about nervously.
And I do say,
you know,
what I'd love to do is like,
do Friday night lights,
but in the world of basketball.
And he goes,
Oh,
you know,
I grew up a little that way.
And he starts talking about growing up,
uh,
growing up and playing basketball in a rec center,
this kind of,
you know,
a very,
very,
very lower class rec center and outside of Maryland.
And then he described it very quickly,
which blew my mind.
He goes,
yeah,
we'd play basketball.
And right next door we shared a wall with an old age home.
And I thought,
well that's pretty colorful.
I mean I could see that.
Cause I always like to know what things look like.
Always,
always,
always.
I won't hire a director unless they even no matter of smarter.
Good.
I have to go,
well what does it look like?
And then they describe the shot,
a shot,
it's a shot is whack.
Then I just don't even do it.
Like if you're doing a comedy and a director gives you a wide shot,
you know who you're talking to,
the wrong guy.
Because comedy is a closeup medium.
So there's a lot of rules and you can not trick people but make them feel
comfortable to tell you their true impulse because they're true impulses with
bill.
Do you know a lot of people think,
oh,
I'll talk him into it.
I'll negotiate my point of view upon them.
Artists.
And they might be true by engineers.
I don't know.
But um,
Maybe it's that,
but artists do what they say in the first few minutes,
not what the,
not what you tell them to do,
you know.
So,
um,
so I met with Kevin did this thing and now we're doing a television show.
We're doing like the Friday night lights version called swagger,
like version of fraud,
you know,
of bad in basketball.
It's very exciting.
Oh,
that's just sort of starting from scratch also.
Do you have a,
a recent curiosity conversation?
You've been doing these for for two weeks,
uh,
or sorry,
every two weeks rather for a long,
long time.
Do you have a recent one that really affected you and that you really just enjoy
it?
Um,
I have,
I have one I can't talk about very much.
I just,
I went to Saudi Arabia to do it actually last week.
That's crazy.
Um,
so,
and not a lot of people have been to Saudi.
I haven't been to Saudi and we think of Saudi as a certain thing.
The beauty of these curiosity conversations,
I've done at least a thousand of them over the 30 years.
Every preconception that I have has been wrong.
I might have a hundred percent track record of being wrong every single time.
So like,
cause whenever you like when you,
whatever you think it is,
wherever you think that meeting is going to be or the Party,
oh,
that's going to be a bomber.
It turns out to be great.
The person I hate is gonna vibe me.
He's not even there.
I mean everything is always wrong.
Like what?
And so Saudi was very,
um,
my preconceptions were very wrong.
Um,
now some of the things in Saudi that you do know are factual,
you know,
um,
as it relates to women and decapitation and things like that,
but that's also on,
it's,
it's on a curve of changing.
Uh,
that was pretty,
that was super heavy going,
going there and doing that.
And most people think of eye contact is just,
you know,
normal kind of etiquette and conversation.
Uh,
why is that so kind of important to you?
You're writing a new book about it.
Oh yeah.
So I wrote a book,
another book.
I wrote this book right here.
Curious mind.
A curious mind was really,
I was just going to write notes on all my conversations that I'd had over the 30
years.
I had notes of the last 20,
but the first 10 I didn't.
And I thought,
I better do this while I still have some motor skills,
you know?
Um,
and then somebody said,
well,
you should just do it as a book.
And then I thought that was an ego trip.
And then someone said,
well,
grace come,
some people come and graze and then they go,
it's not an ego trip.
Everyone knows you don't know anything.
You know,
I thought it would be like one of those memoirs where you're telling people you
know how to live your life and what it blah blah blah.
Anyway,
l basically.
So I did write this book and what it is is,
um,
is sort of two verticals.
One is,
so is the,
is is that,
well one is like the definition of curiosity as a force and a superpower and
it's,
um,
it's a synthesis of many of these conversations I had.
And then that synthesis intersects with,
um,
with narrative storytelling.
Like,
you know,
one conversation I had,
I'm sure,
I don't know if you read this,
but anyway,
I had a woman,
I had a conversation with a woman named Veronica [inaudible] Negray I explained,
she explained to me how she survived torture every single day of her life in
Chile.
Um,
and then that conversation,
what I learned was valuable when I had problems trying to figure out what a
beautiful mind should be and from what vi which perspective it should be
experienced,
um,
like 20 years later.
So all the conversations are just,
you know,
they,
they serve as sort of dots and a greater constellation of dots that you have
faith will some day connect and they do.
So,
um,
I forgot the question.
I think you answered it.
Yeah.
Wow.
Um,
well I want to get to the audience Q and a but,
um,
real quick,
uh,
you know,
Hollywood's changing so much and a Google probably has,
a,
a part a hand and kind of changing it just in terms of content distribution.
Uh,
what do you see Hollywood kind of looking like a,
you know,
in the next 30,
40 years,
30 or 40,
or whatever time scale,
you know,
you think you could,
you could.
Um,
I dunno,
probably every per,
every,
every artist that can create,
sustain a sustainable story will be their own platform.
There'll be consolidation of platforms,
but probably in the future of 10 years,
more artists will have more power over their own life.
Gotcha.
Cool.
Does that
my positive,
uh,
does anybody have questions from the audience?
Thanks.
I'm really appreciated everything you've said so far.
So I worked in film for 10 years and a lot of my friends are aspiring writers,
producers,
actors.
Uh,
I always think the ones who are aspiring producers,
it just seems like the most impossible business to get into.
What advice would you have for aspiring producers?
Well,
I'd probably go back to like having an idea,
having some Ip,
whether it's your own self generated,
I idea,
um,
or just any Ip.
It can be short story.
It can be in,
you have to have some,
if you're going to be a producer,
producer.
Ultimately the definition of a producer is somebody that can generate an idea
that can see sort of the vertical line of the most nascent stage of that idea
till its final
evolution or conclusion.
So you have to be creatively responsible and fiscally responsible.
So that starting point to its end division has to have a corresponding parts
financially and the fight and they'll both things will change all of the time.
All of the butt,
and I,
as I say this,
it's so much like a startup,
isn't it?
Because you know you start off,
you're making a movie every,
let's say the good news is you have this idea,
the studio wants to make it.
You go through this long process of developing a dead and another for sure going
cost $50 million and then they go,
we're making it.
You're in and you feel like,
wow,
great.
They go,
but we're making it 30 million.
Then you have to figure that out.
You have to cut scenes out.
You have to collapse the story or you have to convince them it's 40 w you know,
it's all,
it's a multiple of different possibilities but you have to start owning
something.
So it seems like,
uh,
I think so many of you said like presence is kind of at the core of how you
maintain and grow your curiosity.
And a,
I'm just curious about how you use personal technology in your life and I can
see that going in two ways.
One is a distraction,
but one is an enhancement to your curiosity and how you kind of control your
behavior when it comes to personal technology,
how,
what you use,
how much time you spend in the offline world versus the online world.
I just love to get like what that presence,
more context around what that means in your life.
Well,
I definitely use technology a lot and I,
um,
you know,
I always go,
I mean,
I'm every day I'm doing some search binge because it's because it's fun for me,
but I have to start with some idea and I always found,
I also paint and I've painted for about 20 years or so.
Starting is the hardest thing touching the canvas,
whether it's an idea to become a movie or television show or,
or,
or a painting.
For me,
Brian,
knowing myself,
I can't execute perfection.
I don't approach things.
Anything knowing Brian Grazer is going to execute to perfection.
Um,
I try to have originality as a differentiator.
So the original idea,
um,
is the one that I will put the highest value on and the one and,
and it's the original idea that,
that,
that stress test is the one that I'm interested in the,
to be the greatest artists where you is just not interesting to me.
And I don't think I could succeed at it,
but I think I can have original ideas and there's,
you know,
I like now a lot of evidence that proves that.
Um,
but that's where I put my value is to try to,
and then of course I will employ through collaboration,
the ability to execute it to the highest quality possible.
But I don't start like,
uh,
like Chris Nolan who did dunk Kurt.
You know,
I don't start going,
I know I can execute this to a level 100.
I do sort of think kind of like,
I mean if I were to compare it to any yard decide I'm not this person cause I'm
not as great as this person,
but like Andy Warhol just did original shit.
Like it's,
you know,
that was it.
Um,
he wasn't like Gerhard Richter,
you know,
a scientist art.
So,
um,
that's the word how I look at it.
So I use the,
your Google all the time to enrichen original ideas that I feel like I'm
touching or creating or being part of its creation.
So it's,
it's,
yeah,
it's a,
it's an informal,
it informs all of that.
Cool.
Thank you.
Sure.
Do you have a process for these curiosity?
Conversations are a standard set of questions you ask or research you do before
going into him.
Cause it's,
it's a skill and an art to kind of extract great stories from people as well.
So how do you go into these conversations?
You have to get to the place,
you know,
like in the like get in flow right or in the zone where,
where you,
where are you're hoping for the very best date of your lifetime and through end
by Ha.
If you think about your very best date,
you weren't,
you weren't constructing stuff as it's going,
you're not thinking of,
um,
what are you going to say next?
You know,
it's,
you're really in a state of flow and you're so present that everything is
evolving on the most sincere,
in the most sincere and authentic way.
I think being real,
just being as sincere as possible.
You can be funny and you can goof up like I do all the time.
But I think people feel,
uh,
when other people are a facsimile of authenticity,
authenticity.
I,
there's a lot of agents that I deal with.
I just feel like their bots,
you know,
they go,
hey,
so what's going on?
They,
they come up with questions they,
they sent me.
I learned that that was a method that would create intimacy and it just,
I just don't feel like it does.
Are you smiling because it's true,
right?
When you try to methodology,
methodology dies it.
If you,
for me as I spoke to you earlier,
but I've had some ideas and they're written down and they're not just ideas with
the actual scripts are done.
What's the best way or a way
that you would recommend to getting them produced?
Take getting them done.
Okay.
This will be horrible.
What do you think you can take it?
Just take a guess even if it's the wrong gift.
Sure.
For me,
like submitting to friends in the industry that are producers themselves or
agents,
managers,
I submit to contests and stuff like that.
Okay.
All right.
Good.
But I'd augment that.
People don't really want to dredge through shit,
so I think the best way,
if you're,
if that would be the mechanics for you,
then you should know how to say it.
In a really sexy way in like under a minute.
Got It.
Working on the pitch,
is that what you're saying?
Yeah,
but work on like the sexiest hookey is like words that could be 30 seconds but
it forces the person you're talking to ask questions.
Got It.
People love talk but they only like to talk if they think you're interesting.
Okay,
cool.
Next question.
There you go.
So along the lines of that advice,
can you give the audience an example of your sexiest pitch that you've done?
I was just going to ask that.
Basically my career began when I,
while I was the law clerk and after Lou Wasserman said,
you better have ideas.
There was this book,
this Leonard Maltin is 10,000 titles of movies and movies for TV.
And I realized for me everything started with a title or a word and there are
certain words that really wake you up like revenge.
There are certain few,
look at this if you look at,
so um,
there are certain words that that are,
that are like accelerators,
you know,
that wake you up and they make you go,
what does that mean?
Uh,
that have danger to them.
So I go through this book,
I get these words,
they then became titles or the ignition point of what my question would be.
Um,
I mean I a beautiful mind.
I could do any of them.
I mean you should ask me that.
I can do any,
any of them.
I made three movies all in a year that we're all like young cause my,
the studio dared me to make a small budget movie.
So I made Friday Night Lights,
the movie Friday night lights,
blue crush about the,
you know,
it's that good girl empowerment movie about three girls at surf on the north
shore of Oahu and then,
um,
eight mile and they're all like,
they all began with,
did you know they all have they ever,
I looked at it like this.
You ever,
what looks he watched 60 minutes has been around for 30 years.
I thought to myself,
if I had to work for one of those guys,
like Dan Rather or whatever,
and Dan rather goes,
he only has like a minute,
I'm like a junior.
Nobody.
I said to everybody that works for me,
including myself.
Like I have to pretend like I'm working for Dan Rather.
And I got like one minute to say,
did you know that this thing is going on in central Africa and Kang the Congo
right now that Duh Duh Duh Duh.
Like you have to talk like that.
That would be how I do it.
Okay.
Pr Hype.
And now,
and for those kind of battling it solution meant,
do you think that yeah,
a medium for storytelling that's viable or do you think it's the money?
Well,
I liked your question.
That's a conclusion.
I really like it cause I feel similarly to you and like,
you know,
I've sort of been on the same,
I met the guy that created Vr,
uh,
Jared,
something like a literally 25 years ago in northern California.
Anyway,
do I think it's,
um,
okay,
so I've been to every one of those places.
Magic,
leap,
all that stuff.
I think it interrupts emotionality and,
um,
opt k optimally what movies and television,
w optimally anything that becomes cinematic should it ignite emotion.
And when it ignites emotion,
it becomes indelible and then all of a sudden it becomes a memory that you care
about,
you care to tell others affects you.
I have,
I think VR so far to my,
in my experience that it interrupts narrative storytelling,
which is the map to emotion.
So I'd like it to work,
but I don't,
I haven't seen it yet work that way.
So I always got the vibe that in Hollywood there were tons of aspiring actors
and actresses who are,
you know,
um,
uh,
working minimum wage jobs,
trying to quote unquote make it.
Um,
and probably the same thing with screenwriters.
I always see a bunch of them and Starbucks and so forth.
Are there any roles in Hollywood that you feel like there's actually a shortage
of people for like if we had more of this type of person,
moreover all stuff would get created?
Anything other than straight American?
There's less up.
There's two little rough.
Um,
and it's weird.
It's a very,
it's a very,
the movie business,
which,
you know,
uh,
is sort of positive,
you know,
sort of posited,
are positioned to be like really liberal.
It,
I found it,
it's not very liberal actually.
Um,
it's very ethnocentric.
It's very judgmental.
It's kind of it's own hypocrite in my opinion.
Um,
it lives in its own hypocrisy in that,
um,
you know,
there's usually only one,
like Eddie Murphy,
I'll say,
cause I don't want to say it's me.
Eddie Murphy said there's only thing cause I made six movies.
Eddie Murphy says there's only room for one black funny guy or there's only room
for one fat funny guy.
You know,
there was fatty Arbuckle,
then there's this,
then there's John Candy,
then there's Chris Farley.
There's just,
Hollywood doesn't have a lot of STC elasticity like that.
It should.
Um,
I mean that's my new quest of what I'm going to try to do is,
uh,
not,
you know,
that's why I like to go to like the Middle East and it's like I go to Latin
America,
I like to be on the ground when you're on the ground.
It's not just people are not data.
There are,
you get to see and feel them and then you don't treat them.
Uh,
you don't,
you don't make the Great Wall with Matt Damon.
And I mean it just like,
they just thought,
okay,
these are the requirements.
I'll make the Great Wall Chinese.
They'll love it.
Bang.
Put in Matt Damon.
It was just like,
you can't weld things into things.
Incidentally,
I make a lot of mistakes and movies.
I don't make that particular mistake,
but I,
uh,
you know,
as you know,
my movies and television are fallible too.
I have a good movie coming out by the way that you guys are handling.
It's called the spy that dumped me.
Um,
I'm not trying to just promote stuff,
but it's pretty hip.
It's super funny.
Girl power movie stars,
Kate Mckennon and Mila Kunis.
And I know you got is cool and,
uh,
shot really well,
like great action.
But it's funny,
these chicks are really funny.
Um,
and you guys are working on it.
So that was the sexy pets right there.
There it goes.
Oh,
thank you.
Come back.
Right.
All right.
I think I got a,
I'm sure you guys all have to go.
Thank you for being so polite and nice and everything.
Thank you so much,
Brian Grazer.
[inaudible].